[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without this episode of the
minimalist podcast is brought to you by
nobody well hello everybody my name is
Joshua fields Millburn and i am ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome we are not alone
today as you can probably hear we are at
the Aladdin Theatre in Portland Oregon
hello Portland so what we'll do we have
a microphone set up here we'll start
with three long-winded answers it means
you'll ask a regular question and Ryan
and I will monitor on a little bit and
then after that we'll head into a
lightning round we'll do at least three
lightning round questions maybe more
we've been doing something interesting I
don't know how it's gonna work tonight
because we have a special guest I'm
going to unveil in a moment but these
lightning rounds usually we we will sit
down for a day and and and try to
cerebrate over the perfect tweetable
response but now we're doing this live
and so you're gonna ask your question
and Ryan and I are gonna have a rap
battle
except there won't be any rapping going
on I know yeah but it's the same premise
it's yeah we're it's a little friendly
competition so if you want to line up
while you're lining up someone has to
break the ice obviously and then of
course everyone will cascade down from
the balconies or whatever works
but first what I'd like to do is welcome
a special guest you know back in
December of 2010 Ryan and I started the
minimalists dot-com and around that time
I was really inspired by the person that
I'm about to bring out here he was
certainly one of the people who inspired
us to make a leap into the world of
nonconformity one might say and he's
written a bunch of books he runs a great
local conference here as well it's
called be world domination summit
yeah and he's written some great books
the the art of nonconformity he's
written the hundred dollar startup the
happiness of pursuit born for this and
he's got a new book coming out this
September it's the same name as his
podcast his podcast is called side
hustle school and his book is called
side hustle and I encourage you to check
out the podcast as well as his writings
ladies and gentlemen Chris killable
[Applause]
so we don't do guests on our podcast so
this will be interesting
and we're still not where we definitely
do interviews because I don't enjoy
doing interviews that much on a podcast
but what we really enjoy about the
podcast the opportunity we get to listen
to people and and their questions and
allows us to formulate and better
formulate our responses over time so
we're here to listen tonight and chris
is going to going to help us out before
we dive into that though Chris you you
have have spent some time I should say
bucking the status quo but but maybe you
weren't never part of the status quo and
the cool thing what I really love about
your work is you encourage people in a
very practical way to do things that
seem radically unpractical to most of us
or impractical I believe would be the
word but can you talk talk just for a
moment about about your current project
your you have a great podcast and it's
called side hustle school what what
inspired you to start that podcast and
then the book awesome well thank you so
much Josh Thank You Ryan it's a huge
honor to be with you guys
I've been a fan of you for many years as
you probably know and thank you for
coming to our fair city by the way as
well right
[Applause]
good well I think like you guys I'm
really inspired to create and I'm
motivated to get up in the morning and
make something that I'm interested in
and hopefully there's a connection with
somebody else as well like I don't want
to just you know create for myself I
want to make something that's helpful
and useful and so you know I last year I
had a book out I did a tour of about 30
cities and I would give a talk for about
30 minutes and for about 2 minutes of
that 30 minute talk I would talk about
side hustles and this concept of you
know even if you love your job you
should have at least more than one
source of income and there's there's no
downside to a side hustle it will bring
you more confident it so bring you more
security backup plan you know all this
kind of stuff I just kind of mentioned
that in passing and then I noticed that
after the talk half of the questions
were about that topic and it's not like
I originated this idea I just noticed
that last year in particular I felt like
more more people are kind of responding
to it maybe like you guys saw as well
with minimalism like when you started
and I felt like there's really something
here and when I think about what am I
going to make next what's my next
project like I said I don't want to just
create for myself and so I was like
here's something that I'm somewhat
qualified qualified to do you know I'm
basically unemployable so I've spent my
whole life you know in a series of
trying to kind of find my way so I'm a
little bit qualified and there's a lot
of interest in this and also and lastly
not everyone wants to be an entrepreneur
and I felt like there was a bit of a
backlash against some of this idea of
like everyone should quit their job and
everyone should kind of like jump off
the cliff and take a risk and not
everybody can do that and so I wanted to
kind of speak to all the other people
who didn't necessarily want to do that
like maybe one day but wherever they are
in life like let's do something let's
create something for ourselves like
let's create something that brings
economic empowerment so that we have
more choice so that we can be more
intentional and live the life that we
want so that was the motivation for that
what I like what I really love about
that is it's the obverse side of the
coin because you wrote the book the
hundred dollar startup which the titles
a misnomer right because I think it's
the four
dollar startup is the average business
the average business was like 382
dollars in this study but that's what
that was a really bad title like my
publisher was like you can't call it
that so we went with $100 and and that
was more of a hey if you're if you're
considering taking some sort of leap
here are some templates to prove that
this is possible right it's not pie in
the sky it's not it's not just for this
one person just for this guy this for
this guy it's not just for this industry
here are a bunch of different examples
and now with with side hustle it's like
well here's the other side maybe you
love your day job or maybe you you're
just tethered to it now because you're
in debt and you need to get out and so
this is the way you provide for your
family but at the same time why not find
something on the side that is going to
2ei inspire you be it's something that
you can crew you can be creative in or
be passionate about you can cultivate a
sort of passion and see you can use the
income from that for whatever you want
to get out of debt to to grow your
business and then see where it goes from
there so I think the podcast really it
it's nice because you're still doing a
podcast every day right every day now we
were talking about this earlier today
because we're filming some new stuff
have any of you seen our documentary
nice well if you if you hated the
documentary you can blame Ryan sorry and
if you love the documentary the the man
behind the camera behind the editing
behind everything that was good about
that documentary is Matthew Vella and
he's right here ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
we also have another very talented
filmmaker who's on the road filming with
us this week and throughout a lot of
this tour his name is Conrad and he was
right here let's give him a round of
applause
[Applause]
well grateful to have them on the road
we're working on some stuff we were we
were filming some things with Chris
earlier today and here's the cool thing
it's just like the documentary we filmed
about 2000 hours worth of footage and
Matt somehow was able to make most of
that hit the cutting room floor we ended
we ended up with 79 minutes of just
beautiful film and and we're doing that
again but we don't know the format it
could be it could be anything at this
point and we've gone into it with no
expectations but really high standards
and we're hoping for the best we're just
gonna keep filming until Matt runs out
of hard drive space it's coming up soon
he says well I certainly better hurry up
anyway I was going somewhere with that
and I've told it to totally direct
derailed myself but what we'll go ahead
and move on to some questions I'm sure
it will the the thought will attack me
mid point you're glad to say your name
and where you're from and what your
question is yeah I'm from right here in
Portland Oregon born and raised I've
been a fan of both of you guys for quite
some time now and one of the things that
you talk a lot about is the benefit of
evaluating what your values are and how
in alignment your short-term actions as
well as the people that you're spending
time with are with those values and my
question is how often do you recommend
taking the time to intentionally step
back and re-evaluate that and are there
particular ways that you recommend doing
so by yourself with a partner with
friends with family etc yeah I think
there are four different kinds of values
and I just want to delineate those being
I think it's important to to sort of
break it down and and maybe rank them in
order of importance so Ryan and I in our
first book we wrote
called minimalism live a meaningful life
and in that book we basically said okay
once we get rid of the stuff what do we
fill this life with because it's not
about having an empty life that's not
minimalism where what does minimalism
gonna help me do where is it gonna help
me go and to do that I had to figure out
what are my values I didn't really know
what my values were right and so we
uncovered the the five what I would call
fundamental values or just the
foundational values and health
relationships passion or creativity
growth and contribution I think these
are values that pretty much everyone
shares you may add to that list you may
subtract you can do whatever you want
but but I think that's the the
foundation upon which everything else in
a meaningful life is built so that
that's the the most important start
because if you don't have a foundation
you're gonna build a house on on
quicksand and that's not gonna work out
so well on top of that you have what I
would call core values and those are
gonna change those are much more
individual in fact your core values
could be similar to my core values but I
may place a lot more emphasis on one of
them versus the other so core values
like discipline or freedom or community
or independence or self-reliance or
sexuality I think that there are there
are a bunch of core values and you
probably have a list of somewhere around
to 180 25 of those core values now I
that those five I'm looking at those
first five I'm looking at every single
day and saying are these actions aligned
with those five fundamental values and
then with those core values I try to
look at them about once a month and I
try to reevaluate them about once a year
and so at the beginning of the year and
I find it's nice to do with an
accountability partner as well to just
look through those values and and either
I'll do that with Ryan or I'll do with
my partner Rebecca will sit down and
I'll say what are your values and it
lets me learn more about that person too
right and sometimes she'll come up with
these great values I'm like holy [ __ ]
why wasn't that on my list and on top of
that I think there are other values you
have minor values so a minor value is
something that adds value to your life
but it's not an absolute necessity to
your life so some examples of that might
be social media maybe you get value from
social media or maybe it's for me it's
caffeine
like I get value from coffee right and
I'm in the right city for that right now
and I definitely value from coffee but I
need to make sure that my minor values
don't creep into this fourth area and
these are the imaginary values and we
need to be really careful about those
imaginary values because what I find is
that I may get some value from social
media but the truth is if I'm using at
all time I'm incessantly checking it on
my phone constantly scrolling through
Facebook or Twitter or Instagram I'm not
actually getting value from it it's
imaginary value because it's not the
best use of that time and so I have to
be careful and have a balance there that
the things I do get value from I don't I
don't abuse them I don't overuse them so
they fall into some imagined space where
they're actually getting in the way of
my real values and so I think it's
important to to constantly look at all
of those I do it at least once a month
you can do it less frequently but I find
that so it works really well for me ya
know I think it's so important to to get
those at least the fundamental values
like if I was to ask you right now like
hey what are your fundamental values you
could probably list some things off I
don't know if you've like actually
written those down or not but without
like actually getting clear on those and
writing those down it's really hard to
remember those when it's like the most
important time to remember those like I
was I think about like when I was trying
to incorporate a workout routine into my
into my daily life and I would get up
and like you know 7 a.m. 7:30 a.m. and
the night before I was like so ready to
workout in the morning
[Music]
and I had like all these great reasons I
was gonna work out but then like I'd
wake up and I'm like I'm just gonna hit
snooze for like 20 minutes and then like
you know another snooze and other snooze
and then it's 9 o'clock and now I'm like
well I don't have time to work out I
guess I'll have to like start that
tomorrow and what I started to do is I
started to like write those reasons down
in my memo pad on my phone like why do I
want to work out well I want to be
healthy I want to I want to feel better
I want to you know be able to go on more
dates with with people you know whatever
it was like I had those reasons written
down so in the morning when that you
know alarm went off at 7:30 a.m. I could
pull that up and I can look at that and
I could recall them right away and you
know this is not like a magic bullet
answer but it certainly did get me out
of bed more than that I would stay in
bed but what I love about like those
foundational values is that for me like
that is my compass those foundational
values so Josh talk about those 5 things
earlier health relationships cultivating
a passion or creation growing
contributing whenever I feel out of the
balanced like that is when I start to
look at those five areas and if you can
imagine like those areas being like
buckets of water or like buckets of sand
however you want to envision that the
least full bucket is as happy as I am if
that makes sense so like you know I
could have a full bucket and
relationships and creation and growing
and contributing but if I don't have my
health then I'm not happy and you know
same thing with relationships I can have
very everything else but if I got crappy
relationships and I don't have anyone
around me to support me you know
especially as an extrovert like I need
people in my life good people in my life
so I I always use that as my compass
whenever I'm feeling you know kind of
down whenever I'm feeling a little
stressed out I've got to like look at
those areas and ask myself where is that
least full bucket and it might be like
oh wow like I haven't talked to my mom
in a couple weeks you know I need to lay
I need to reach out to her see how she's
doing or you know when I go on the road
like
get some exercising but it's not nearly
as much is what I'll get in it at home
but you know might be that where I need
to you know focus on my health a little
bit more and eat a little healthier um I
just got back from Japan and man the
diet just like what to crap over there
I'm not even gonna lie I like started
out really really well and I kept up the
intermittent fasting for like 90% of the
trip um but yeah I got over there just
like when it came to you know all the
delicious candies and all the other
awesome things they have to try over
there like I just couldn't resist and
you know all the peer pressure I totally
gave into it so not perfect but what
I'll say is that getting clear on those
values of beliefs it is so important and
you know going to those other levels
that Josh was talking about those those
have the possibility of changing over
time I don't think they change too much
but certainly they do change a little
bit and I would recommend especially you
know for those who have a partner you're
living with someone like sit down and
write down what your all's values are
because you know for the things that I
value aren't necessarily especially
those core values aren't necessarily the
same exact things that my partner Mariah
values but what her and I do is we are
clear on what each other do need in our
lives and getting clear on those helps
us to support each other it helps us to
appreciate one another hey Chris do you
want to add anything to values you and I
were having a really good conversation
about values earlier today and and if
you were to if you were to talk about
some of your core values and and maybe
how you discovered them sure yeah that's
great I mean I feel like you guys are
more self reflective than me and I could
learn from your process you know I kind
of think about you know my values and
how they align with actions and goals
and all of that usually once a year I do
like an annual review I remember when I
was starting though and it was kind of
like going through a period of change in
transition maybe to the question before
as well like if you're going through
this time of you're trying to move from
something to another maybe you're
looking at those things much more
frequently
and like when I was first trying to like
put something forward and make a lot of
changes I had this screensaver my
computer I would open it up and it said
why do you do this every single day and
I would look at it I have to kind of
answer that right and it was also very
cluttered with like icons and documents
I feel like I should apologize to you
guys for that like you asked to come
over to my house earlier today and was
really worried cuz I was like man I feel
like I have a lot of [ __ ] everywhere to
put it up you know how I kind of
stumbled on those values I mean I think
it was like I think it's important
understand we don't always like go on
this search for our values I mean
sometimes we do actually stumble upon
them and we find them through a
discovery process and so for me I think
you know if I pick a few core values its
independence self-reliance you know
freedom there's a little bucket for that
and that kind of comes from my childhood
and adolescence and always kind of
wanting to you know do things for myself
and then maybe the second value for me
is gratitude and just realizing that I
do feel very fortunate and I've been
able to do a lot of things and I have a
pretty good life and so the third value
that we talked about earlier today was
kindness and that's something that I'm
trying to just embrace embrace a bit
more my brother passed away about two
years ago and that's affected my life
obviously to make a grande
understatement and something that we've
learned in kind of looking back you know
on his life is that he was very kind and
when people talked about his life they
would say you know ken was very kind and
this was like something that was
characteristic of him and in reflecting
upon that I realized that you know times
in my life but I haven't been kind there
are there times in my life that I've
said yeah you know like yes I'm kind I
embraced this value but not really you
know or maybe I say that but I can see
you know parts of my life where I
haven't done that and so I've tried to
be more conscious of that so I didn't go
on a search to find that it just kind of
came to me yeah beautiful thank you
honey hey guys it's nice to meet you in
person Chris nice nice to meet you as
well
I'm a native or you grew up in Banks
Oregon anyways I think this is a good
good question so I've got I've been
listening to your material since right
before Christmas which is kind of a
shocking experience because you learn
the information and the orgy of
Christmas happens nauseating right but
I've been trying to go through as much
material as I can it's amazing what
you've done at this point in time
changing lives it's great I'm you talk
about dealing a lot of financial issues
and and getting out of debt and that
type of stuff and one thing I haven't
heard you guys addressed yet is the
concept of bankruptcy in situations you
know we were going through this two
thousand seven eight nine ten
period of time I am a consultant to some
degree with regards to finance and
consulted people through the bankruptcy
process you also talked about getting
out of business I mean getting out of
debt doing side hustles and stuff like
that and and that's really I'm what I'm
seeing in the future from the generation
coming up as side hustle right because
there's no full-time work anyways you
know you talked about embracing
minimalism moving on I know there's a
character-building aspect of working
hard getting second jobs and paying your
debts
I get that bankruptcy dots you tell me
what your thoughts on bankruptcy are no
we're on the verge or it's begun the
bankruptcy of multi-billion dollar
corporations that you were a part of you
look at the malls you look at the stores
you look at the headlines
Sears BB all the stores are going out of
business right multi-billion dollar
bankruptcies those costs being thrust on
to the community and or you know people
losing jobs to suppliers stuff like that
I think that bankruptcy allows an
individual to get back into the
purchasing market when all of your funds
are being diverted to pay for the debt
then you're not out there supporting the
local businesses you know contributing
in a financial way so I think that it's
a I think that there's a hesitation
naturally the humans people because we
feel obligated to to pay people back and
I appreciate that it's a beautiful
aspect of it however from a business
standpoint from a technical standpoint
from a corporation standpoint a lot of
times that's built into the business
model right bankruptcy is is this how it
all ends everybody right so I I got some
you know the pros and cons I I think
that it's a legitimate question
considering the advice the great advice
you're given people and I if you could
touch on that I mean I get to be talking
well let's let's talk about the side
hustle thing because I think that's
that's important it's one thing we don't
often think about like I was very
tethered to a lifestyle I was making
$200,000 a year in the corporate world
which in Dayton Ohio is more than
$200,000 in Portland
we used to call our they used to call
Dayton little Detroit and that was a
compliment in the 1950s and it still
rings true today and so you know I live
pretty close to downtown Dayton and it
was 65% of the skyscrapers were were
vacant so a lot of bankruptcy certainly
happened throughout the the 80s and 90s
and in you know once we were into the
the consumer mode where the malls had
had plagued the outskirts of town and
everyone sort of fled from from the city
center it left a lot of blight in in my
hometown so I'd like to talk about side
hustles because I think I think it's one
route but we need to identify what that
means because I don't when Chris talks
about side hustle I don't think he's
just talking about going and driving for
uber or lyft no that's right well thank
you for the question as well and you
know your personal circumstances it's
kind of hard to comment on but for the
broader picture you know when I started
this project it's like what what is a
side hustle because this phrase is in
the culture and we need to define it
just like minimalism and it can mean
different things to different people of
course but I guess the way that I'm
thinking of it is it is an
income-generating project it's not just
a hobby or a passion like it's great to
have things that we do in our life not
for money but aside festival is
something that is actually bringing us
that kind of empowerment and it's also
ideally something that we have ownership
over not that we want to necessarily be
a quote-unquote entrepreneur because not
everyone wants that like I said earlier
but you know if you're driving for uber
or lyft or whatever that's a good
part-time job and there's nothing wrong
with having a part-time job like most of
us have done that but you have no
control over that there's an income cap
you're completely dependent on somebody
else's platform there's there's very
little creativity to it so you can set
you can set your own hours and that's
good that's why it's a good part-time
job but I guess what I'm interested in
is helping people create security and
create assets for themselves and part of
the reason why I'm really kind of jump
into this after maybe even getting away
from it a bit for a couple years after
the hundred dollar startup is I just
continue to see the impact that it has
on people's lives when for the first
time they make money even a small amount
of money relatively that's not coming
from their employer it's not coming from
their paycheck and I get emails all the
time like people that are just like
ecstatic about like I did this little
thing on the internet and I made this
little website and I got a PayPal
notification and like you know it was it
was $100 and it was great you know
they're like I worked 40 hours for that
hundred dollars but that's not that's
another story you know no it's just so I
think when you create something for
yourself whatever it is it just opens up
possibility it opens up opportunity and
there's no downside to it right there's
no downside to it as long as you're not
investing a lot of money in it and
you're starting quickly to see what
happens if it doesn't work great you've
learned something and you're gonna do
something different and the reason I
wanted to incorporate that is I think
it's important for us to look at
alternatives to bankruptcy bankruptcy
certainly something I thought about in
the past because I made $200,000 a year
but I spent more than that that equation
just doesn't work and so I made good
money but spend better money and I was
at a point where you know I had six
figures worth of debt almost half a
million if you count my mortgage and I
was underwater in the mortgage because
the 2008 collapse and yeah I certainly
thought about it but I also realized
that that seems to me like a last resort
as an individual right and so I'm not
I'm not necessarily against it I'm
against it for me under most
circumstances and because if I made a
commitment to pay off something then I
want to do that now here's the other
side of it though some institutions are
incredibly pernicious we have something
called predatory lending right and so so
I can't say that every in every scenario
we you we should always pay back the
person who tricked us necessarily it's a
it's an individual thing you know there
are only two countries in the world
whose norm is a 30-year fixed
a mortgage I'm 35 years old if I buy a
house right now and put my 10% down and
and and sign up for a 30-year mortgage
it's like I have no idea what I'm gonna
be doing 30 months from now let alone 30
years throat from right now and quite
the responsibility I think we don't
think about it I know I built my first
house when I was 22 and 0% down big
house in the suburbs and I did it
because they let me do it was it my
decision yeah absolutely I had the
agency over that decision without a
doubt and so I'm responsible for it but
should they have let me do it I don't
think so I mean I look back now I was
like me there should have been a few
more hurdles for me to at least make me
think about it
right and so we were sitting down the
other day with dr. Christopher Ryan he's
a he wrote a book called sex at dawn and
and he we were on his podcast recently
and he was talking about we were talking
about the mortgage thing and he was like
you know I think I figured it out I
don't want to be in any debt for the
rest of my life until I turn like 70
he's like the business model they just
keep loaning you money even if you're 70
you can get a 30-year loan and he's like
yeah so I figured like I'll just coast
until then and then I'll sign up and
take advantage of their system because
no one's gonna pay you back when I'm
gone
sorry personally I'm not gonna do that
but I find it interesting yeah I mean I
have I know some friends and family who
have used bankruptcy as a last resort
it's certainly there as a mechanism like
you I loved how you presented it as it
allows you to free up funds to to put
back into the economy
I think at the end of the day because
this I mean talking about bankruptcy is
it this is a it's a hard conversation
right and well not for you but I mean
just for other people I mean to talk
about Bank it's hard for me to talk
about it and I guess to anyone out there
who is looking at
bankruptcy I would say you know this is
a situation where someone has obviously
been misguided or made a mistake and and
you know what I'm just gonna like say it
straight like they made a mistake at the
end of the day when I think about the
people I know who have one bankrupt they
have signed up for those 30-year
mortgages expecting to you know make the
money that that were that they were
making on day one and when they signed
up for all that debt and to be able to
continue making that money for 30 years
that's just not a smart plan especially
with how volatile the economy is right
now and I want to be clear like you know
it we're not against consumption Josh
said that in his talk like it's it's the
compulsory consumption um if everyone
stopped spending money today the economy
would crash and when we spend too much
the economy crashes so you know I think
minimalism kind of helps us find that
balance we do have to consume some
things but we have to do that very
deliberately especially for signing up
for debt payments I mean I just became
debt-free for the first time late 2015
so you know just in our two years thank
you
and you know i i i do plan on buying a
house one day if I what if I were to buy
a home and I didn't have the money to
cover the cost you know I might take a
loan out I might you know put down 50%
or 30% take out like a seven-year
mortgage or something but I wouldn't
make that decision unless I had the
means to do that so I guess when it
comes to bankruptcy yeah it is totally a
tool for people to help you know reset
their lives but I guess wherever
encourage people out there who are
looking at bankruptcy or who are you
know they've already decided they're
going to do that use this as a learning
example I mean I screw up all the time
like I wish I could tell you like hey if
you bought all our books and watch our
documentary you're gonna live a perfect
life like it just just doesn't work that
way but for me it's about you know
learning from those mistakes and acting
differently it's about having more wins
than losses as I move forward in life so
you know anyone out there who is looking
at bankruptcy I would use this as like a
very big wake-up call to to live their
lives differently moving forward thank
you
hi howdy I just wanted to say that um I
you guys are a huge inspiration to me
and I'm very grateful that you're here
so thank you thank you for supporting us
thank you what's your name oh my name is
Devin I'm from West Center Washington
but I work in Portland so it's like my
second home
my question is is that my husband he's
the one I brought here was he kicking
and screaming as you dragged his little
body
I had a nut Gemma little I can point so
since I've been following you I have
found my journey and however I need some
advice tips or tricks because he hasn't
yet or she has a little bit I will give
him a lot of credit but what are some
advice to make sure we don't sleep in
separate bedrooms
[Applause]
what what's your journey so um it was I
was I had a really sad time in my life
for myself and you guys came along and I
watched and I watched your documentary
and I had everyone watch your
documentary and then I watched it again
and I read your books followed you on
Instagram all of that obsessive thing
and not I'm not a stalker yeah so I got
rid of like 90% of my things I mean I
can't have 20 pieces of clothing and a
round of applause for that
[Music]
that is [ __ ] awesome so and you know
I found that I wake up happy I go to
work be stressed it's a huge way of not
just even the simplest thing of picking
out my clothes for the day and you know
I have like four pieces of jewelry now I
mean just very minimal things and I have
one box that I keep my mementos in like
my dad shirt or kids teeth there's
something like that weird I know I'm
like kind of going got to save them
dental records they're your kids right
yeah that's so funny I actually used to
be a deputy coroner but you know they're
my they're my kids is T a tooth okay I'm
just gonna change that but anyway so my
question is is that like so when you
walk into our room my my how I you can
just see the difference my half is so
nice and my husband's is a yeah that's
nice yeah so what is something that you
know he he is I do have to I mean he
needs a round of applause for being an
absolute supportive man because this man
will support me if I quit my job
[Applause]
[Music]
if I quit my job and dream unicorns
forever he would be fine with that and
so he supported me on this path with you
guys and I just need to know how we can
combined households when we're when's
the minimalist and when is a packrat
sorry minimalist have him open his mind
and you know a minimalist like okay so
here's here's the first thing you you
used a couple words there and I could
tell this path you're going down and I'm
optimistic for you first often and
here's why the first thing I first thing
I heard which actually really worried me
you talked about your half of the room
at his half of the room that's a huge
problem because there's no such thing
that's like having if you're bit if
you're married and have separate bank
accounts yeah I mean because it's like
well well why what's the real problem
this is a band-aid on top of something
else and what you're talking about is if
we I have this is my half of the room
and you you know you can't cross this
line I mean there are sitcoms that are
predicated on this no he has his own
like little nightstand he puts his stuff
on and I have my own little table I put
my stuff on and sure his lots of stuff
in very little our closets are totally
different although the first thing I'm
going to encourage you to do is to get
on the same page just to start finding
the same vocabulary because you're using
things like his nightstand and my
nightstand
they're yours as in the collective or
the plural you it's your house together
right and so it's and it's hard to hear
this it's also your clutter and you may
you may not be responsible for it but it
is yeah it's
it's part of your life and and the worst
thing that you could do is try to
convert someone to minimalism or to your
way of thinking that's not why we're
here tonight I'm not trying to convert
any of you to minimalism although we
have certificates out in the hallway
there for sale for $20 each no I mean I
don't
I'm not proselytizing what we're trying
to do is share a couple different
recipes that have worked well for us and
try to help other people on that journey
but I know that you can't change people
in your life but what you can do is show
them the benefits and realize the reason
that you're on different pages right now
is because you experience different
benefits and he he has not seen those
same benefits and the news is he may
never see those benefits from from
letting go and that's okay but also what
I'll tell you is he most likely will
most people see some benefits from
letting go of excess but those benefit
has benefits gonna be different from
yours they may be financial in nature
while yours might be I want to tie to
your space I want less physical clutter
so I have less mental clutter
I want fewer things in my life so I have
fewer bills so I can then spend that
time with my family and friends or I can
create that thing that I want to create
I can start that side hustle right and
those are the benefits for you but his
benefits might be completely different
same with your kids the kids I mean I
have a three-year-old and the benefits
for her are completely different for her
the she loves the fact that we don't
have anything in the house because she
gets to ride her little bike around and
and anytime there's clutter like it's
the first thing she'll say is like if I
get if I get rid of this it means I'll
have more room to ride my bike around
the house and so she already at three is
able to start understand what the
benefits are for her I don't use that
same language but it's about getting the
the right vocabulary there starts
talking about our stuff in our house and
our clutter
and never accuse anyone of well this is
your clutter it's your stuff and said
help them see the light by by shedding
some light on on the benefits I'm we
have six kids so they all seen the light
you know in their rooms and our garage
you can't walk through our garage right
now but he's he's not like oh I won't
ever let go of anything I just wanted to
know how is the best to coexist coincide
with - he'll hold on to like you know
things and I'm just like no let's what's
not you know the word that stood out to
me the most was support and first off I
just want to say the fact that he's here
is not be a sign that he supports you
and I gotta tell you I was you know I've
been in a lot of relationships romantic
relationships where either I wasn't
being supportive enough or I wasn't
being supported enough and I just I just
really and I'm sure I know you
appreciate it
but I just really want to like point
that out because not everyone has that
so like that that right there is that's
half the battle is just being able to
love and support one another and you
know I think past that supportive past
the support would be appreciating the
other person so like when I think about
Mariah and I when we first met we met on
OkCupid by the way I went on like a
million dates and and I was the first
date she went on like we've been
together for almost four years and I
like tried to explain to her how lucky
she is
I mean not just to have me
[Laughter]
but how she didn't have to like a filter
through all of the the BS but I'm going
on a tangent now but I remember when I
first met her like she was just
absolutely gorgeous and just awesome
personality we clicked like right away
and I remember after dating her for a
couple weeks
eventually was over at her place and
noticed how many pairs of shoes she had
I mean she had like two pairs yeah
mother one yeah like she didn't even
have one yeah no she had like 60
something pairs of shoes I mean it was
unbelievable and I remember like having
this moment where I'm like okay dude
like you can you can either continue
dating this wonderful person and you can
you know even though she likes all these
shoes or you could get rid of her shoes
or auric or I could at break or I could
I got rid of her shoes for her when she
wasn't looking that is not what you do
or I you know I can't continue the
relationship but you know what that was
something that I was willing to accept
and I was willing to not just accept it
would appreciate it and not just you
know support her but you know move past
that support to appreciate who she is as
a person now after you know us being
together for four years I'll tell you
she has seen the benefits and she had I
mean I don't know how many pairs of
shoes she has now I certainly don't keep
track I certainly have never asked her
ever to get rid of anything there might
be there might be a nudge like don't get
me wrong like if we got papers scattered
on the counter all right we really need
to go through like these this mail and
like figure out what's going on cuz this
is getting to be a big stack I mean
there might be some things like that but
never have I went to her and I'm like
you know what I know that you loved all
those shoes when I first met you but I
really thought you would get rid of
those by now
and they got to golike I've never I've
never had that conversation with her so
I guess two things is the the best thing
you can do I think right now is to
continue to love and support your
husband and to appreciate the things
that that he loves and that doesn't mean
that you know he gets to walk all over
you I mean he has to do that back to you
he has to love and appreciate and
support you as well so you know there
might be a hard conversation that has
that you know that needs to have and
just of going back to that previous
question of values and beliefs of really
getting clear on what each other's
values and beliefs are what is most
important you and what is most important
to him and figuring out a way to kind of
you know dovetail those together but you
know I'll tell you when Josh and I first
started the minimalist calm my it was
like a month after we started it and my
mom called me up and she was like hey
son how you doing I'm doing great mom
how you doing
she's like I'm I'm well what's this
minimalist crap and I'm like oh you
found the website I'm like okay like you
know what do you think she must have
been like googling my name or something
cuz like we had not told anyone about
the website and she's like I don't know
what to think I mean she's like are you
uh you're not gonna be around for
holidays anymore are you depressed are
you can I not buy you stuff anymore and
I'm you know I'm like mom I will
certainly be around for holidays in fact
that's about the only time I ever saw
her was like during major holidays
birthdays Mother's Day stuff like that
which by the way mother's days tomorrow
[Music]
but uh but you know I was like mom I
hope to see you more than just the
holidays in fact like I'm going down
there sir because I really need to
reprioritize how I'm spending my time
and what my priorities are and this is
something that is helping me do that and
yes I am depressed like I am really
depressed and I'm really trying to get
out of this and I'm trying to live my
life differently and I said you know
when it comes to buying me things like
no like I'd rather you not buy me
anything like just spend some time with
me and you know that'll be enough and
she said well I'm your mother and I'm
still gonna buy you things anyway and I
suppose like she has the right to say
that as my mom I guess um and I told her
I'm like well you know if you do buy me
something that I can't use like if it
doesn't you know serve a purpose in my
life if it doesn't you know bring me joy
I'm probably gonna have to like find
someone else to give it to or like you
know donate it to Goodwill or something
this is not the thing to say to your
mother by the way she got pretty upset
and we kind of went back and forth a
little bit but you know I got to the
point where I just kind of reeled her
back in I'm like mom you know I love you
so much you love me right she's like
yeah of course I love you
I'm like I want you to be happy you want
me to be happy too right she's like yeah
of course I want you to be happy I'm
like well if that's the case I don't
need you to have a packing party I don't
need you to be a minimalist I'm not
gonna come to your home and judge your
things all I need is your support in
this journey that's it and that's what
really kind of got through to her so I
would just again just continue to
support your husband I'm sure he will
support you back things don't happen
overnight but you know if you guys can
get clear on those values and beliefs
and really truly love each other and
want each other to be happy which I know
you both do I'm sure you can figure out
a way to to combine everything
[Applause]
[Music]
alright before before we move on
don't worry you'll get to ask your
question if anyone who's listening to
this at home or in their car or on a
treadmill or whatever you're doing with
our voice in your ears right now if you
have a comment or tip for anyone who
asked a question today you give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine and we will air our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode or you can also send a voice
memo right from your phone to podcast at
the minimalists comm Ryan what time is a
you know what time it is it is time for
our hashtag ask the minimalists
lightning round and they we're usually
on Instagram and Twitter and Facebook at
the minimalists and you can follow us
there and ask those questions but since
you're here in front of us let's go
ahead and do it here this is this
lightning round is where Ryan and I and
now Chris who has been roped into this
we we try to answer your questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response and that takes a
little bit of rambling before we get
there usually and then you will be the
audience will gauge who is the winner of
each round so the pressure is on all of
us at this point will go ahead and get
your question and you can ask a normal
question we're just going to give you a
pithy answer well thank you guys so much
for coming to Portland um I've been
what's your name Oh my name is Amelia
and I'm from Portland also and so first
of all on a serious note Ryan you're
looking really jacked I'm really excited
for whatever whatever you're voting for
so my question is so I've been consuming
your message through Allah tereus
formats over the years and my
interpretation is that you've been
communicating about your corporate
experience with like this dark cloud
kind of but I'm really curious if
there's a if there are ideas or concepts
or skills that you've been able to use
from that experience to spread your
minimalist your minimalist message yes
good one what are they yeah there we go
yeah I'm trying I'm trying to think of a
pickup hit the answer here but it's
gonna be something like my well here let
me ramble but yeah I mean absolutely so
I I couldn't be the person I am today
without my past wins and losses that's
my tweetable answer thank you and just
to expand briefly on that yeah
absolutely I am a terrified introvert I
really am there are three things that I
hate more than anything else and it's
travel crowds of people and public
speaking
and and chris has been to all 193
countries in the world and yeah I I
don't envy that at all yeah I love you
Chris but my god that sounds like
purgatory but but know that the truth is
I was an extreme introvert at 18 and I
got that corporate job and it was a
sales job and your for you like just
forced into interacting with people for
eight hours a day and then 10 hours a
day and then 12 hours a day and over
time you become less terrible and
terrified at doing that and I can tell
you now the reason I can interact with
people even as an introvert even as a
person who spends 80 percent of his time
alone is because that was a skill I
picked up and having to interact with
people and the same goes for for the
rest of my life I learned about business
as I was building a business and you
know I had retail stores at one point I
managed 150 retail stores which is
really ironic with the whole minimalism
thing but but I I learned I learned
through that process how to run a
business what to do what not to do how
to hire people how to fire people and I
can't say that I enjoy doing that but I
built this skill set so I know how to
bring people onto a team and build a
team now and I'm I'm really grateful for
the team that we we have in fact Jessica
you around here somewhere she's right
here look at that so jessica is is a
talented member of our team she runs all
of our social media and just doesn't
outstanding job she has a great podcast
as well called the mind palace you can
check that out on iTunes
and but the reason that I could do that
now and this the thing that's different
from that old corporate world is my
experience in that corporate world was
dark but I'm not saying that
corporations are inherently bad or evil
what I'm saying is what I did there
didn't align with the person I wanted to
be and so yes that's the actual nice
part about leaving is I tweezed out the
skills that I got and the good things I
learned from that and pulled those
things forward we had someone a few
weeks ago say to us it seems like you
guys didn't give up anything important
to which I responded no why would I do
that
right the whole point of minimalism was
to have the right things the important
things and let go of the rest and so
that applies to the skills as well yeah
I uh I definitely learned a lot from the
corporate days I mean yeah it was
definitely a net negative there's no
doubt about that and as you said we've
written a lot about that talked a lot
about that um but yeah I mean the the
public speaking definitely helped just
being at you know having to get up in
front of you know a couple hundred
people selling cellphones and like
motivate them to sell the
five-year-old's
to you know talk them into uh yeah you
gotta have that yeah you're five years
old I mean you're gonna start texting
soon you might as well get that text
plan - yeah it was it was it was crazy
but you know but thanks to give you gave
me a piece of 140-character answer to
you by the way appreciate this nice so
you know at the end of the day like what
I did it did not align with my my long
might short term actions in my job did
not align with my long term values and
beliefs so I guess you know my tweetable
answer would be you know you're in the
wrong job if it doesn't align with the
person you want to become
Chris it's on you yes well I was
thinking at first I should probably pass
on this question since I have no
corporate experience and was fired from
every job I ever had basically and uh
you know this whole thing this whole
question about you go to a job interview
and they're like why should we hire you
for this job like I feel like if I ever
had that experience I would say honestly
you probably shouldn't you know but
despite the lack of corporate experience
I have some experience working with
groups of people in organizations and
teams and I mean to touch on what you
guys have have said already I do think
that the soft skills like leadership
communication follow up being that
person that gets things done because in
every corporation or organization you
can always kind of identify that person
and that person is is more valuable in
lots of ways than the person who's more
technically advanced and there's always
somebody like somebody can always learn
another programming language than you or
advance further in whatever the
technical skill is but you know if you
have a team of five people or ten people
or whatever there's always like you know
tasks are being handed around they're
like what was your name Amelia Amelia
they're like Oh a Melia like she's good
at this let's give this to has to has to
her because she's gonna follow up on it
like that I think is valuable throughout
life and so I guess my 140 character
would be you know it's not so much the
work that you do it's it's how you do it
and that's the value that can transfer
[Applause]
thank you I think I won that one will
give it to you we go all how you're
gonna win anyway
howdy my name is pun rad and I live in
Eugene welcome thank you for being here
without you so my my question is to
accomplish being minimalist do I have to
become a monk oh my god that's great you
know it's funny we gave we gave a talk
in oh man Edmonton
Edmonton Canada the West Edmonton Mall
it's the biggest mall in North America
the only person who's ever been there I
bet is Chris yeah yeah and it was
totally full of irony and it's funny cuz
like people were giving us so much crap
for it they were like we can't book
you're gonna go to the mall and use it
as a venue I can't believe that and Josh
I were talking about her like well the
other side of the spectrum is we would
go to a you know monastery a monastery
and and talk to a bunch of monks like
where do you think we should be like in
the belly of the beast is the best place
to be yeah no actually my real question
is do you feel like you're the
minimalism that your practice informs
your sense of spirituality we won't need
a tweetable answer for this one I got a
tweetable answer I'm totally recycling
it go for it oh yeah what I'll say is
you know thank you so much for asking
that question we we will get asked a lot
about like what our religious beliefs
are and what's about spirituality and
stuff and you know like we'll be in line
and someone will come up to us and
they'll say it is so nice to see two
young Christian men going out and
spreading the message of Jesus Christ
and Josh we just like what kind of smile
and we're like you're welcome like this
and we got an email a few months back it
was like you know Mohamed Mohamud was
the the original minimalist in and now
we have a monk who is you know is you
know uh spreading the message of Buddha
and you know I think that it what's so
awesome about minimalism is we will have
I'm sure there are Christians here I'm
sure there are all types of people there
there is a monk here and I think that's
what's beautiful about minimalism is
that it is something that or a threat I
guess that threads a lot of different
cultures and religious communities
together so my tweetable answer would be
it does not matter what religion you are
or what God you worship they all want
you to live a simple life yeah
I think I think my short answer has to
do with with our possessions it starts
with that right so it's gonna be
something like this our material
possessions are a physical manifestation
of our internal actually so our material
clutter is a physical manifestation of
our internal clutter mental clutter
financial clutter and spiritual clutter
Chris you got an answer for him I don't
know if I have a tweetable no I'm
thinking about it just ramble til I get
something's out the strategy okay great
usually we have like a date okay well I
was born at a young age went from there
I think I think the beauty of what you
guys teach and you know what a lot of
people have adopted in different ways is
the kind of stripping away of the in
essential and I guess for me when I
think about like what if my struggle has
been in this area I mean maybe a little
bit of consumerism materialism at
different points but I think for me the
greatest struggle it wasn't wasn't so
much possessions I didn't really feel
weighed down by that I felt weighed down
by I don't know if it was obligations or
you know use the word stuff which is
interesting cuz stuff is like it could
be anything right and so for me the
stuff that was distracting me from my
purpose or those values that we talked
about a bit ago or whatever it wasn't
something that I had to like physically
get rid of it was it was more of like
what matters to me and what do I believe
in to go back to the question and what
am I going to do about that and so I
think whether mentalism or intentional
ism or whatever the word is that's
that's what helped me write so I'm still
rambling I haven't got to the hundred
you totally had it there it was
the access allows you to figure out what
you believe in that's it grant thank you
it was good that's good thanks look at I
appreciate the team effort and then Kris
swoops in and steals the round nice all
right thank you appreciate that howdy
there's a little tall ah hi my name is
Jean I live in Sacramento California
right now also it's currently 85 and
sunny it is in fatica Lee Northwest here
today but my reason for being here is
over there his name is Jesse and in a
year I will be moving back here to build
a tiny house with him awesome very cool
but we have one area which we haven't
really been able to simplify and that is
as good environmentalists we cook
everything from scratch so we have you
know the rice cooker the griddle the
dehydrator the blender the stick blender
crock-pot you know just cuz all of these
things make it a little more efficient
to cook but they also take up a lot of
space and I was wondering I know you
guys on the road right now but when
you're at home like how do you cook how
long does it take you and like what do
you make yeah you know I'm gonna be
interested to hear Chris's answer on
this because he and actually I'm
interested to hear the the travel answer
because my travel hack while we're on
the road is just Whole Foods because
like we right now there are what six or
eight of us on the road together it just
depends on the week which I know when
you call yourselves develop minimalists
everything you do is then blanketed with
irony and and so yes but we will go to
Whole Foods because there's always
something that someone else someone on
the team can eat there you know with our
many different allergies or or
preferences or whatever else but at home
man I am I'm the worst person and the
best person asked this question of
because it was up to me I wouldn't even
have a kitchen
well I would but they're just be like a
coffee maker but thankfully my favorite
restaurant in Missoula Montana is at
home because my partner Rebecca who runs
a great website called minimal wellness
she yeah there we go
she is just an amazing cook and I'd say
yeah I don't think all of her
accoutrements could fit into a very
small kitchen but I can also tell you
that man she is so deliberate about the
things she holds on to and the things
she brings in and she has conversations
with me has conversations with herself
about do I really need this and also
what other functions will this thing
have so ultimately she's trying to
figure out how few things can do what so
here's my short answer for you how few
things can do the most activity so
that's not even in this sentence that's
not coherent we've been on the road for
a while if I if I don't have I'm just
gonna keep doing drafts here look I like
to get up at 3:30 a.m. and I have no
idea what time it is but it is it is
late at this point alright so what I'm
getting at is is having fewer things
that have multiple functions is the best
way to to organize or the best way to
cut the clutter and so I think I think
with you with your tiny house you have
to to figure out hey maybe it's not
gonna be as tiny as you want it to be
maybe you need another hundred square
feet oh my god does that make it a less
tiny house my tiny is more tiny than
your tiny
and I think the truth is what's
appropriate so here's my answer
bring into your life that which is
appropriate you know I have learned like
being on the road
yeah Whole Foods is definitely a staple
like that is kind of our go-to because
especially yeah like you said we got a
team of people everyone's got different
allergies so there's something for
everyone there but what I will say is I
can go to a 7-eleven and get some
almonds and some like beef jerky as long
as there's not like a ton of sugar in
there like that's usually like I have
been in those pinches before but it's
still I want to say easy but it's not
impossible to still eat healthy no
matter you know what especially in this
country I mean you have access to so
much stuff no matter what story have
access to you can find something that
that is healthy ish I guess I don't know
I mean even subway like you can go get a
salad like really I mean when I was a
vegan there's a subway in the bottom of
our corporate building and I remember
like just going down there and like the
first time I ever went there I'm like
okay what can I get and like literally
was like all right lettuce tomato just
made like a salad just some like olive
oil and dressing and without all the
bread and the meat it wasn't I mean it
was pretty bad but but still it was
still fuel it was still you know it's
look at me buy um oh man I'm just trying
to ramble and come up with 140 character
response here what about at home what do
you do at home
oh yeah I mean at home usually like Mar
and I will get a recipe and like try and
cook it together and sometimes it turns
out awesome and other times were like
like we try to cook saag paneer
which is an Indian dish like just you
know cheese and and some creamed spinach
and some naan and what we had I mean it
was really good but it would did not
taste like saag paneer or non like it's
really tasty but but no we will we will
definitely cook the other we don't have
I mean she's got like the the breadmaker
thing that she will use the mixer we got
it we have a blender but this is not
helping me with 140 character answer um
man uh here's here's what I would here's
what I would can I say no you please it
doesn't matter how good of an excuse you
have there's really never a good excuse
to eat a bunch of crap
[Applause]
Chris when you travel you you you have
rituals sure sure I was gonna say I
don't know that I could comment much on
cooking since I've never cooked
basically in my life you know however
can I just make an observation what was
your name Jean Jean you know as a bit of
an outsider here I feel like you're
basically in like the 99th percentile
99.99% I love anti-consumerism like you
have a tiny house you what did you say
before you know like you cook you cook
everything from scratch like you're
doing really well so I'm not trying to
say like cut yourself some slack I'm
just trying to acknowledge like what
Joshua said like you do what's
appropriate to you right like you've
come so far or just not to say you
shouldn't you know go forward so when I
think about travel like people often ask
me it's not so much about the cooking
it's about the packing and and I
actually am you know pretty rigid and
pretty minimalist in the packing and I I
do take the same things with me pretty
much everywhere or wherever I'm going
around the world for however long I'm
going it doesn't really matter because I
have a system and sometimes people have
said like you guys probably have this in
different different ways too it's like
like isn't that hard how do you do it
and my answer is like this is actually
better this is easier for me like this
is benefiting my life right it's not a
cost it's not a sacrifice or anything so
to maybe wrap it up and go to the short
answer you know in your quest to go
further I think it's good to have it to
always always improve but it's also good
to acknowledge like how far we've come
so I would say there's always something
we should be proud of and there's always
more we can do
[Music]
that's all the time we have for
questions I want to apologize the folks
that are still in Lyon we will we don't
have time to get to everything I'm sorry
but I think I think Chris pulled it out
with that last answer ladies and
gentlemen Chris peel oh thank you guys
hey before before we wrap up here just
real quick we we like to do an added
value segment Ryan and I talked about
what's been adding value to our lives
recently and we're doing something
that's more local some City centric
Portland centric stuff here yeah so one
of my favorite coffee houses in the
country is here it's it's a place called
barista and that place I hope to I hope
they're open on Mother's Day because I
didn't get a chance to go there today
but I did go to a place called good
coffee and that is some damn good coffee
what about you Ryan what do you been
enjoying in Portland I just had to pull
my phone out cuz like I had to remind
myself where I just ate dinner at but so
I just like medic a couple friends over
at the Brooklyn House Restaurant oh my
god like unbelievable food yeah I had a
I just had a bunch of stuff I was I
always like to ask like the waiter or
waitress when they're like taking my
order I'm like this was my last meal and
it might be what should I order in like
they just had an awesome recommendation
the staff was awesome and the food was
just I could still be over there eating
if yeah I would totally check that place
out of here the mini cool
all right let's move on the right here
right now let's talk about what's going
on in the lives of the minimalists as I
said tomorrow is Mother's Day but it's
another special day Shawn were you I you
bet I'll there he is he's back there at
the booth podcast Shawn ladies and
gentlemen yeah tomorrow is his birthday
Marky Shawn yeah man thank you for being
here thank you for being the man behind
the minimalism if the podcast sounds
outstanding it's always because of him
in fact we're building a new podcast and
film studio so we can create more
meaningful content especially with the
video side of things if you love their
documentary we're working on a lot more
video stuff we hope to be doing a video
version of the podcast and live
streaming a bunch of other stuff because
we refuse to clutter our podcast with
advertisements you can all help out with
that if you want to support us on
patreon whether you're at home or you're
here in the theater with us you can just
go to the minimalists com click on
donate at the top and you contribute per
episode or one time it's really up to
you how you want to do that you can help
us by the way none of that money not a
penny of it goes to me Oh Ryan it goes
to build the studio also to help pay
podcast Shawn a full time because he has
a wife and three kids and a family to
take care of and so we're trying to do
good by him as well and and if you can't
afford to yeah thank you but if you
can't afford to donate any money to the
podcast to help us build it that's
totally okay you can also help by
leaving us a review on iTunes and for
the people who are listening at home we
are all in the middle of a tour right
now it's called the lessons now tour and
you got to listen to a little bit of it
we're coming to 40 cities so it's a city
near you you can find all the cities
dates and theaters over at les is now
calm after this little event Ryan and I
will be out in the lobby in about 20
minutes or so we will dish out some hugs
we will hey hello
hell yeah you can get a hug they're free
and you can also pick up a book if you
want if you can't afford a book we'll
buy one for you so you're welcome to
grab a copy of one of our books if you
would like it and oh I need to say thank
some folks let's say thanks the Aladdin
theater for having us
thank you oh by the way if you pick up a
book out there please minimize it
afterward pass it on to someone else who
can give value from it a library a
friend a family member someone else it
will do you no good sitting on a shelf
collecting dust right and so I see if
there's anything else I'm forgetting I
always do this and so I have my let me
see I've got my little notepad here this
is the we stand the lap of luxury this
is the Hampton Inn thought pad I
mentioned the tour I mention I mentioned
patreon I mentioned hugs
oh yes and there's one other person I
want to thank you I want to thank you
for being here I know cost money to get
in here because we have to rent this
theater we have to pay all the people
and Ryan and I don't really make any
money from Torian but that's not why we
do it and we allows us to contribute to
other people in several different ways
but that's not the only one thing you
paid for being here you gave up your two
most precious resources your time and
your attention tonight and we're
grateful you decide to spend at least a
few hours with us tonight and if you
leave here with one message I hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works
thanks for being here y'all thank you so
much for long
[Applause]
hi this is Joe and Alice and I was
burning through some old minimalist
podcast and I heard you talking about
the ketogenic diet and cure bacon and I
just wanna throw out there that they do
sell unfair bacon at a lot of places now
including Walmart that have less than
one gram of carbs keep it up hi Ryan and
Josh this is Kathy from Illinois I have
a comment for Susan who had a baby in
the NICU I have also had a child who was
in the NICU and she's not 20 years old
what I did was I have two children
each child got one Apple box go to the
grocery store at the produce manager for
an Apple box it has a top and the lid
and you put what you want to keep in
that Apple box baby clothes I have a
quilt that was made by a dear friend and
as the years go by you only get the one
Apple box per child my children are not
22 and 20 and I've opened that box and
they've looked in there and none of that
means anything to either of them but it
means a lot to me so Ryan josh has also
said that everyone has their own version
of being a minimalist well my children's
baby stuff is very important to me and
it has extreme value to me so I'm
allowing myself to apple sized boxes for
my children stuff and I don't feel even
a little bit bad about it so there's
also some clothes in there when they
choose to start their families they'll
be able to use some of those clothes
hi my name is Jamie I'm calling from Los
Angeles California and then to leave
this a long time ago I feel like it was
on one of the debt episodes but it
actually pertains also to the budget a
friend of mine I can't take total credit
for this but recommended that I check in
with my cell phone bill I had noticed it
was really high for two cell phones and
I admit even though I'm very organized
when the bill comes electronically I
don't always look at it so I won't give
the provider the name per se but I did
call I asked to make my bill lower which
they did have something to offer but
then we combed through the bill on the
phone and I had apparently some kind of
featured at 399 a month for
international calling I never call
international calling so that came off I
had some kind of ringtone charge that
was happening I didn't know about anyway
long story short I found all kinds of
hidden charges that I did not know that
were happening for years I lowered my
bill right then and there by $60 I
wanted to wait a few months to see if it
actually stayed that way and it has so
it's been about six months so when we
get bills electronically we don't always
look at them so I just urge people to
check in to especially a cell phone bill
that has some of these charges we might
not even know because $60 times 12
months of a year has been a huge savings
for me as I try to get out of debt
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little scene that's just feeding
your green oh I bet that you'll be fine
without
[Music]
every little thing that you got ahead
every little thing that you got hey you
gotta reach for and you gotta grab oh I
bet that you'll be fine
without your team
[Music]
you